you kid it it's important to get the
shape of the head just right and the
lips and mustache tomb Doral mascara
cure desert can sell Chuck Adam can
practically draw the Turkish president
in his sleep he has years of practice
Adam is one of turkey's most well-known
political cartoonists his satire
magazine called penguin is an
institution but Adam finds himself in a
tight spot in this sarcastic caricature
president add one is portrait
celebrating press freedom in Turkey
reality is quite the opposite amah and
misery chinder this satire is critical
by its very nature satire expresses what
no one has the nerve to say out loud
she's who limit Irish little Dawson love
alum B mana faithful but the staff at
penguin magazine has to be careful
because some people find the very idea
of caricature as an insult in bee
buzzing sound origin and Kara Catherine
Chisholm is available pocket the
magazines biting images have triggered a
few lawsuits over the years and every
trial is costly given turkey's economic
crisis and the drop in the newspaper ad
business penguin magazine is in dire
straits this edition is one of the last
to go to press it's no secret that
newspapers have to fight harder to
retain their readership it's a challenge
faced by journalists all around the
world in addition to this reporters here
in Turkey are under increasing political
pressure and many of them have to make a
choice either stay critical and risk
problems with the authorities or just
keep quiet
but some journalists are undaunted dawn
Oakland is editor in chief at T 24 one
of the only independent online news
outlets left and Turkey
he's convinced that the government and
its supporters are using existing laws
to target journalists they don't like
solution diggity GB as ever whenever a
reporter is arrested for writing or
saying something critical it sends a
message to thousands of other
journalists you could be next
learning can be optically robust and
that's how you end up with
self-censorship Malala asana diploma
donors in Sonora de guiche Otis on suit
anything for mercy does he ever think
about giving up its pollution never
aside from the fact that I can't do
anything else
I think journalists in Turkey have never
been as important as they are right now
are we worried absolutely but that's no
reason to keep our heads down and high
we will serve as journalists as long as
we can build easily khabar so look at
our turkey to give it is really hoc
jong-seok
Adam isn't giving up either even if his
magazine has to fold he's not putting
down his pen he and his staff have
created an app for their political
cartoons which have already gone viral
now the penguin brand of satire has a
good chance of survival